dance is something that comes in every
last one of us
from birth
what we do is take that and give them an
opportunity to personalize it
and then it empowers us
to dance at this level
my name is melva mitchel aco and i'm the
founder of northwest tap connection our
mission is to close the gap for
underserved communities for an emphasis
on children of color and really just
open that door for young people who
would not be able to have accessibility
to the arts because of cost to have
those opportunities that are enriching
when i started norfolk staff i was
working for the seattle police
department and my goal was that children
that i got to see on a weekly basis i
would never see across my desk this walk
in peace is very much about our culture
and you need to dance it that way tap
dancing is the foundation of our
organization
i strive to make sure that children
understand that it is a dance form that
comes out of black culture
let me see that it comes out of protest
and we have to appreciate it
embrace it and protect it as we pass it
down
northwest tap is a race and social
justice oriented studio and being an
african-american male i don't think had
i danced at another studio that i would
have been surrounded by so many fellow
african americans and i feel like that
has given me the confidence to feel
comfortable in my skin
and normal everyday life i don't really
like talking very much but when it comes
to dancing i am able to just communicate
in a way that touches people rather than
what they're just hearing
my feelings as i watch young people
dance
there is this sense of pride for the
work that they do
but then
at the same time
there's this sense of fear and trouble
for me
how much longer will we continue with
this struggle
dance is such an empowering tool
we are a community of many colors many
genders
identifications
but we are one
through these children that dance
we're creating
a new tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you